in 1885 a young woman named Elizabeth
Cochran sent a letter to the editor for
hometown newspaper the Pittsburgh
dispatch she was responding to a letter
by a man that the paper had published
earlier under the title what girls are
good for this man the father of five
girls had not so subtly implied the
answer girls are good for birthing
babies and tending to households and he
had even invoked China's then policy of
killing girl babies as some kind of
justification for an act of mercy that
would spare girls the drudgery of their
destiny of being women in the world
young Elizabeth Cochran's letter it was
a rebuttal so impressed the editor that
she was hired as a reporter and she went
on to become a trailblazing journalist
that paved the way for women in media a
couple years later when she was only 23
she pulled off one of the most
extraordinary feats of investigative
journalism she had heard rumors of
patient abuse and mental asylums and so
she feigned insanity and checked herself
into the women's lunatic asylum in
Blackwell's Island there under cover she
endured horrible mistreatment and she
barely got out to publish the expose
under the title ten days at the madhouse
it was an instant sensation so much so
that the public attention she brought to
the abuse and the horrific things that
were happening to patients led to a
grand jury investigation in which Bly
herself assisted that produced a 1
million dollar increase in the budget
for care for the mentally ill in New
York City and forever changed their
legal protections another couple of
years later at that point Bly is 25 the
newspaper for which she worked began
losing circulation and so she took
matters into her own hands and devised a
publicity stunt that she thought would
draw attention back to the paper it was
kind of an honorable clickbait if there
ever was such a thing this was it
integrity at the risk of the journalists
life so she inspired by Jules Verne's 80
days around the world decided to do a
real-life version
the journey packing little more nothing
more actually than a small devil bat she
managed to beat
Vern's fictional journey by eight days
and said the world record for the first
fastest real-life voyage around the
world in 72 days in the novel Verne had
written anything one man can imagine
other men can make real and here was a
woman who made it real a woman who
shaped the future for women in
journalism